The jogan Experience he credits talking
to you and taking your advice is
completely changing his life and now he
feels infinitely better yeah I mean he
did a lot of the work himself well he
had to but you had to tell him what to
do but luckily he listened yeah I mean I
think I think giving him a life
expectancy just kind of validated it for
him it just really put it in his face
uhhuh and you know cuz that's something
you can calculate he's like okay well
I'm 53 now 63 doesn't seem that far off
right you know a lot of like high stress
individuals that don't take care of
themselves their ticker checks out yeah
around 65 67 that's pretty standard it
just takes its toll I mean and and the
funny thing is you know uh when you go
back and you look at the the pictures of
him prior to oh yeah he does kind of
look like he was about to pop you know
it's not good yeah he had a big old moon
face and he was you know veins up on the
forehead and the veins out of the side
of the neck what was uh like first of
all how did he meet you how did this
this come about and like how did the
conversation start so we have a mutual
friend um named Carrie kasm if you
remember uh Casey
KAS worked with her back in the day in
the early UFC's okay so um uh you know I
recently met uh Carrie and she had kind
of a life-changing experience as well
you know if you know anything about her
journey with Lyme disease and chronic
viral infection I mean she really she
really struggled and ended up healing
herself and um she took the same test
that that that Dana White did it was
lifechanging for her and she was like
what is this test it's a genetic test it
looks at um genetic methylation Pathways
so methylation Pathways methylation
Pathways word mean so think about it
like this um you know we pull crude oil
out of the ground right but but you
can't put crude oil into your gas tank
right because the car doesn't understand
that fuel source so what happens is
crude oil has to be refined into
gasoline and then the car can run okay
so in human beings there's a similar
process called methylation there's not a
single compound known to mankind not one
there's no vitamin no mineral no amino
acid no nutrient no protein no nutrient
of any kind that enters the human body
and is used in the format that we put it
in without a single exception everything
we put into our bodies has to be refined
into the usable form if you can't make
this conversion you have a deficiency
it's this deficiency that leads to the
most common ailments that we suffer from
so that process is called methylation
and there's several genes that govern it
um this is where a lot of the
misconception about genetically
inherited disease comes from right we'll
say um well Joe you know your
father-in-law has uh not your
father-in-law your your father on your
mom's side had hypertension your
grandfather had hypertension now you
have hypertension so you have
genetically inherited hypertension or
you have familial
hypertension well me hypertension is
commonly known as high blood pressure is
high blood pressure yeah high blood
pressure but 85% of all high blood
pressure is what we call idiopathic
right it's of Unknown Origin so we say
that things are genetically inherited
because they run in families but it's
rarely the disease that's passed from
generation to generation what we pass
from generation to generation is the
inability to refine a raw material which
causes a
deficiency which leads to that disease
and what generally leads to hypertension
so um if you look at um ad Dana White's
case right is a perfectly uh common case
in fact the Journal of hypertension
published an article in uh November 19th
of 2017 um if you want to look that
article up and essentially linking an
amino acid in the bloodstream um called
homocysteine
uh to hypertension and the reason for
this is you got homosysteine in your
blood I've got it in my blood um
everybody listening to this podcast has
homosysteine but if you have an impaired
ability to break homosysteine down right
to take that amino acid homocysteine and
convert it into a harmless amino acid
called methionine if you can't make this
conversion homocysteine Rises causes
something called hyper homos symia High
homosysteine the blood when homocysteine
Rises as it becomes one of the more
inflammatory compounds in the human body
as it's cruising by the inside lining of
the artery it starts to irritate the
artery it actually reduces the artery's
um elasticity and can even cause it to
constrict so think about this you got
63,000 miles of blood vessel roughly in
your body it doesn't take much narrowing
to drive pressure up think about it 85%
of all hypertensive diagnosis diagnosis
of of high blood pressure um primary
hypertension or essential hypertension
are idiopathic right Unknown Origin only
15% of them are secondary hypertension
of where we know the exact cause and so
what we do is we take people that have
high blood pressure we we run a bunch of
tests on them EKG it's normal EEG it's
normal heart and lung sounds cardiac
cath D Contra study we do all these
cardiovascular tests and they all come
out normal yet the person still has high
blood pressure and that's largely
because the high levels of homosysteine
are causing vascular narrowing I mean
this is a fixed system right so if I
make the pipes smaller in a fixed system
pressure goes up so in in Dana's case
specifically and his you know he's
throwing his blood work out on the
internet so um you know we can talk
about his Labs but um in his cases he he
had one of the highest levels of
homosysteine that i' personally ever
seen in our CL clinical team had seen
what So when you say high blood pressure
could you define like I'm not good at
that whenever I get my blood pressure
they tell me the number and they say
it's good I go okay what's a good number
so um 120 over 70 120 over 0 what's high
130 140 150 160 when does it get
dangerous 140 150 starts to get
dangerous people walk around at 140
150 160 all the time and they don't know
it it's the silent killer you don't feel
it you think you would feel high blood
pressure but very often it's the silent
killer because you don't feel it it's
not like you hear your blood rushing in
your ears although you may it's not like
you feel pressure in your head or
pressure in your neck or pressure in
your chest that's why high blood
pressure hypertension is is one of the
silent killers in cardiovascular disease
right in fact one of the one of the
first primary symptoms is sudden death
right so we we often put people on
hypertensive medication before before we
actually look at whether or not they
have high levels of homocysteine or
whether or not they might have a gene
mutation specifically called MTR and you
could test for it or
mtrr and what this Gene codes for is it
codes for the enzymes that break down
homocystine and turn it into an amino
acid called methionine right and so if
this conversion is impaired and this
homocysteine starts to rise and your
vascular system constrict
it can drive your pressure up and it
drives your pressure up without anything
being wrong with the heart so then we
start standing on the heart which is
what happened in Dana's case beta
blockers calcium channel blockers
diuretics all of these things his blood
pressure was still through the roof what
was his number I think he was
160 160 over 110 I want to say it was
very high um and it was consistently
High um we were actually you know
clinical team was taking his blood
pressure two or three times a day seven
days a week and it was consistently very
elevated even though he was on blood
pressure medication really so statins is
that what he on so statins was what
you'd use on uh cholesterol like like a
repath or anything so those trying um
what's a the
hypertension they they're called beta
blockers like enderal calcium channel
blockers we call ACE inhibitors um
sometimes we use diuretics and so he was
still jacked up even though he was on
those oh he was still jacked up even
though he was on medication and what are
the other factors like what what other
things cause hypertension well I mean
cardiovascular disease and there are
certain you know direct genetic links to
cardiovascular disease but they're
they're very rare um but diet AOS
sclerosis you know narrowing of the
arteries arterial sclerosis Harding of
the arteries calcifications in the
arterial wall um can cause pressure to
go up um you know um regurgitations in
the in heart valves can cause you know
pressure to increase but when you think
about the heart as a muscle right and
all four chambers are circulating blood
normally and it's got a good vascular
Supply but it's beating into constricted
pipes think about what happens that
pressure is going to back up right and
so we rarely go outside the heart to
diagnose whether or not and and for the
record I am not a physician I'm not
licensed to practice medicine I'm a
human biologist um I didn't you know
learn my trait in in medical school I
took eight years of undergrad and and
postgraduate education in human biology
but for for 20 years I was a mortality
expert in the insurance industry and I
just read medical records for a living
so the vast amount of what I've come to
understand about modern medicine has
just come from Reading thousands and
thousands and thousands of medical
records and you can see very often that
when people were being diagnosed with
high blood pressure they were always
looking at the heart they never looked
outside inside the heart to say well
could it possibly be beating into a
dysfunctional arterial system and so in
Dana's case and I I should have brought
the numbers because I had the week over
week numbers it was astounding you know
we we just put them on a simple amino
acid called trimethyl glycine you know
an amino acid you can get off the shelf
and what it did was it made up for this
genetic deficiency this lack of code to
break down homosysteine and his body
started to methylate to break homo
down and is this a amino acid that
pretty much everybody should be taking
it's an amino acid that everybody with
um uh hypertension should consider if
they have high homocysteine and explain
say the word again what is it what's the
amino acid called trimethyl glycine TMG
capital T Capital similar to regular
glycine no this is trimethyl glycine
it's a little bit it's a little bit
different than the amino acid glycine so
trimethyl glycine will actually help to
metabolize to help give the body the raw
material it needs I I should write this
down I'm G write down trith he's
going to be on trimethyl glycine
tomorrow well I just want I just want to
keep track of all these different things
you're saying and often times I do
forget so Trine I'm write trimethyl
glycine or just put Capital TMG that's
what it'll say on the bottle
TMG okay and so you know some sometimes
I use the analogy that you know when I
was when I was getting my second human
biology degree I was in grad school get
my human biology degree I had to take
all these plant botony courses um which
I hated but you have to take them
morphology aalap fites and all these
crazy courses about plants but the one
thing that really stood out to me by
taken all these plant bi biology courses
is that if there's ever anything wrong
in the leaves of a plant like the tree
the um you know the trunk the leaves uh
or the branches and you call a true
arborist or true botanist out to your
house they won't even touch the leaves
or the branches of the trunk of the tree
the first thing they'll do is they'll
cortest the soil and they'll go you know
what this soil's deficient in nitrogen
and then they'll add nitrogen to the
soil and the leaf will heal but we don't
think about human beings like this
anymore I feel like there's such a
positive understanding of of deep human
physiology in in a lot of the medical
community not all the medical community
and we don't actually have faith in
mankind and humanity and the body's
ability to heal itself and whether or
not they might someone might be
deficient in a raw
material not pathologic or diseased so
for example in Dana White's case he was
diagnosed with idiopathic hypertension
which he essentially did not have he was
being medicated for it he had been
medicated for it for 15 years and he did
really have hypertension there was
nothing really wrong with him it's that
his body couldn't break down
homocysteine it was deficient in the
amino acids needed to break this
homosysteine down as soon as we put
those back in his body it started to
function normally and where would you
generally get those Amino acids if you
wouldn't weren't taking them um I mean
you can get them online I mean there's
lots of great man you weren't taking
them is it are they in food is it oh
yeah they're in they're they're in Foods
that's why if you look at certain diets
like high folate diets like carnivore
diets um diets that are high in dietary
folate leafy greens um um grass-fed
Meats um um eggs dairy you'll find that
they have lower incidences of um cancer
diets and high dietary folate so this is
a raw material that we can get from our
food but very often our food is just so
nutrient deficient right we update the
macros on the back of a lot of labels
but if you look at the micros like how
much spinach uh how much iron is in
spinach or calcium is in spinach or how
much um nutrients are in the on the
label of most Foods I mean it's a
fraction of what's actually listed there
and so we're nutrient deficient right
human beings are not as sick as we have
been led to believe we are the majority
in my opinion of pathology and disease
as we know it today are nutrient
deficiencies missing raw material in the
human body and we just accept all these
things as a consequence of Aging weight
gain water retention you know lack of
sleep poor focus and concentration lack
of waking energy hormone imbalance and
we think that the body has all of these
different pathologies and diseases but
the truth is it's usually nutrient
deficient it's astounding what happens
to human beings when you give their body
the raw material that it needs to do its
job I mean it really is and so if if
you're just supplementing for the sake
of
supplementing then there's only a
marginal chance that you're getting what
you need if you're supplementing for
deficiency that's when magic happens in
the human
body